[Musica]
ci sono tre parole chiave che la musica
risveglia creatività umorismo ed energia
cominciamo con la creatività la musica
insegna che la ricchezza non sta tanto
nella nostra dotazione iniziale quanto
in ciò che ne facciamo nelle variazioni
a v di rage mano mozart sceglie un punto
di partenza semplice quasi povero una
nota filastrocca infantile
[Musica]
ma poi ci mostra quanto lontano possiamo
andare se questa partenza è anche il
punto d'attacco di un processo creativo
ecco allora che con questo nostro
materiale povero possiamo costruire come
se fosse un lego fatto di suoni una
deliziosa cena di marionette che
trasformano il pianoforte in un
palcoscenico e creano un teatro dei
suoni
[Musica]
oppure possiamo reinventare il suono
della filastrocca affidandola a quattro
campanili che idealmente si rispondono
da punti diversi dello spazio
o addirittura la filastrocca può essere
l'occasione per la più spettacolare
delle metamorfosi per cui il pianoforte
si trasforma in un'intera orchestra
nella quale anziché esseri campanili a
rispondersi sono famiglie diverse di
strumenti
[Musica]
c'è una sintesi molto bella di tutto
questo fatta dallo stesso mozart in una
lettera quando scrive i nobili non
devono sposarsi in base alla more ma
solo in base all'interesse ma noi povera
gente comune non siamo nobili e neanche
ricche siamo invece umili e poveri e di
conseguenza non abbiamo bisogno di una
moglie ricca in quanto la nostra
ricchezza si estingue con noi perché
l'abbiamo tutta nella nostra testa
come vediamo questa ricchezza creativa
ha molto a che fare con la capacità di
cambiare prospettiva sulle cose
ecco perché la musica può risvegliare in
alcuni casi anche l'umorismo nella sua
sonata opera 10 numero 2 bethoven
finisce il secondo movimento in un clima
stupefacente di bellezza solitudine e
rari fazione poetica
[Musica]
a
delle grandi altezze spirituale degli
ideali levati e del più profondo sentire
con un clima del genere
uno si aspetterebbe che il movimento
successivo che chiude la sonata cominci
a tono cioè nello stesso clima è invece
altro che altezze spirituali una rosa
fanfara da caserma con un'aria da
canzonaccia da osteria non dico ma quasi
a osteria numero 9 i soldati far le
prove che mi fermo quindi primo elemento
umoristico la smentita flagrante il
brutale contrasto con le aspettative
ma la sorpresa è doppia perché è vero
che il materiale musicale è rotto ma il
trattamento che vettore ne fa non lo è
affatto
sentite cosa succede
le voci entra l'uno dopo l'altra e si
rincorrono questa tecnica e il
contrappunto nome che già dal nome
stesso temibile evoca profondità
speculativa dottrina artificio teorico
quindi secondo motivo umoristico il
dissacrante connubio tra materiale da
caserma e trattamento musicale
sofisticato e di prim'ordine quindi tra
sacro e profano è il beethoven contadino
scarpe grosse e cervello fino
non è finita
quando sembra proprio che vettore abbia
indossato la parrucca e abbia deciso di
giocare a travestirsi da papà bach e
quindi fare il piccolo bach beethoven
stesso con un doppio squillo un doppio
segnale
manda tutta la dottrina e la scienza a
farsi benedire a vantaggio di uno stile
molto più modernamente dinamico
[Musica]
il terzo motivo umoristico e quindi la
liquidazione beethoven si disfa da solo
del dubbio gioiello di oreficeria del
dubbio pezzo di oreficeria che egli
stesso si era costruito infine non
facciamo in tempo ad esaltarci per
questo nuovo stile modernamente dinamico
ed energetico che tutto improvvisamente
s'inabissa scomparendo ingloriosamente
nell'indistinto borbottio di una pentola
di fagioli
come si vede
l'umorismo a che fare con un continuo
cambio e ribaltamento di prospettive lo
definisce perfettamente milan kundera
nel sala raccolta di saggi i testamenti
traditi dove parla dello humour lampo di
vino che rivela tutta l'ambiguità morale
del mondo e la profonda incompetenza
dell'uomo a giudicare gli altri lo
humour l'euforia che nasce dal conoscere
la relatività delle cose umane
il vero piacere che deriva dalla
certezza che non ci sono più certezze e
dunque l'umorismo è una prospettiva
sulla relatività delle cose infatti
nessun fanatico lo possiede a dir la
verità salvo i cattivi dei film di james
bond che fanno una vistosa eccezione ma
in generale
l'umorismo spiazza e fa riflettere
generando nuove idee e nuove energie e
siamo alla terza parola chiave energia
nella prima ballata chopin introduce il
secondo tema lasciando dissipare
completamente l'energia che egli stesso
ha creato poco prima
perché lo fa perché vuole creare una
situazione tipicamente ad energia vero
c'è una situazione con un tono lirico
quasi da confessione intima con il senso
in questa confessione di rituale di
qualcosa di profondamente soggettivo
personale e appunto unico individuale e
anche con la sensazione state un po che
meraviglia
di una luce che bagna la musica di
nobile solitudine
il tutto sotto voce per tutto questo
chiaramente serve una situazione a
energia zero
verso la fine del pezzo riprende lo
stesso tema ma questa volta in
situazione di energia massima e quindi
anziché arrivarci da una fase di
dissolvenza ed evaporazione dell'energia
ci arriva da una fase spettacolare di
ricarica energetica
[Musica]
l'effetto è uno spettacolare impatto
sullo stesso tema nel quale però questa
volta a causa dell'alta energia i tre
valori prima sono completamente
ribaltati per voi
non c'è più il tono lirico ma il tono
diventa grandiosamente etico
nell'attualità bruciante del sentimento
dell'ora presente il respiro emozionale
della storia del mondo
non c'è più il tono di una confessione
individuale ma la sensazione di una
coralità collettiva e infine quella luce
di nobile solitudine si ribalta nella
gloria di una pienezza condivisa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la musica ci mostra quindi l'energia
come principio trasformativo delle cose
chiudiamo con un brano che sintetizza
tutte e tre case parole chiave avevo
definito la creatività come capacità di
cambiare punto di vista sulle cose e di
mettere a frutto le risorse soprattutto
ebbene qui in questo brano che è il
terzo dei tre preludi di gershwin virgin
ha addirittura mette a frutto le risorse
di due intere tradizioni musicali la
classica e il jazz
c'è inoltre dell'umorismo perché
l'introduzione la mette giù in grande
stile annunciando solennemente qualcosa
di sinistro e di minaccioso
che però non arriva la montagna
partorisce il proverbiale topolino al
posto di qualcosa e minaccioso e
sinistra arriva una situazione
fumettistica che io chiamerei appunto
malavita da fumetto
e da ultimo l'energia è proprio un pezzo
questo ad alto voltaggio in cui
l'energia tiene infiene situazioni
diverse unificandole in un ritmo
mozzafiato che non dà tregua allo
spettatore e su questo chiudiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]